اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه ليله
الماضيه ثمانيه فلسطينيين في عمليات دهم
وتفتيش في قلقيليه والخليل وبيت لحم
بالضفه الغربيه وقال جيش الاحتلال في بيان
حمله الاعتقالات تاتي ضمن عمليه كاسره
الامواج على من يشتبه في تورطهم بانشطه
ارهابيه واضاف الجيش انه ارسل المعتقلين
الى مراكز التوقيف للتحقيق معهم
قال نادي الاسير الفلسطينيين سبعه الاف
مواطن فلسطيني تعرضوا للاعتقال من قبل
السلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال العام
المنصري واشار في احصائيه اصدرها صباحا
اليوم الاحد ان من بين المعتقلين ثمان 282
طفلا ومئه واثنتين وسبعين امراه وحسب
البيان فان قربت ثلاثه الاف من المعتقلين
كانوا من القدس المحتله التي شهدت اعلى
نسبه اعتقال خلال عام 2022 كما اصدرت
سلطات الاحتلال اكثر من 2400 امر
بالاعتقال الاداري حق اسرى فلسطينيين لا
تملك لوائح التهاب ضدهم ولم تتم محاكمتهم
او ادانتهم وتعمل بيان سلطات الاحتلال
بممارسه القتل البطيء بحق الاسرى
الفلسطينيين من خلال الاهمال الطبي حيث
بلغ عدد الاسرى المرضى 600 اسير بينهم 200
يعانون من امراض مزمنهم 24 مصابون بامر